[Musique]
4 195 hectares d'étangs 5 ravine le
cadre de vie de nombreuses espèces le
potentiel la réserve naturelle de
l'étang saint paul n'est plus à
démontrer et si tous les acteurs majeurs
se sont retrouvés pour recevoir le prix
ramsar c'est qu'il s'agit d'un événement
derrière ce label ramsar qui a une
importance 1 c'est un label très
élitiste qui reconnaît des zones humides
d'importance internationale
donc c'est quand même pas rien on a on
est à la recherche d'un gagnant gagnant
sur le territoire c'est gagnant gagnant
où la porte à travers la très
l'attractivité de notre territoire un
regard avisé sur un site d'importance
local national et international
et vous savez que convaincre prend du
temps il faut du temps mais faut des
générations pour que les gestes soient
de bons gestes et que les gens prennent
vraiment conscience la réunion c'est une
poule aux oeufs d'or
mais est ce que tous les réunionnais en
en conscience l'étang de saint paul et
dans la commune de saint paul mais ça
concerne tous les réunionnais nous
savons les temps de bois rouge nous
avons le grand étang tout ce qui peut y
avoir l'étang du gol
tous les habitants doivent se sentir
concernés et se dire tous les plans
d'eau devrait connaître le même
dynamisme et la même protection tout en
laissant les usages aux habitants le
chemin pour arriver à ce label n'a pas
été de tout repos
depuis plus de 20 ans cet espace naturel
sensible et protégé est géré par le
département réserve de l'étang d'art
contemporain pour loi qui a créé réserve
la compare aux réunionnais raison ben là
qu'on tient à la nation bien la
frontière du mali d ivoire nous devons
la préserver
heureux quand on voit tout ce qui est
fait pour améliorer la situation de ces
espaces naturels notamment de l'étang
saint-paul un vrai travail remarquable
de préservation mais quand même un peu
inquiet parce que sans cesse il y à de
nouvelles menaces qui arrive en appel de
la mousse des fous et la mouche
orientale il y à des lianes qui
envahissent les forêts réunionnaises et
ses espaces ici notamment l'eau l'eau
deviendra une denrée de plus en courant
c'est pour ça qu'ils nous convient de la
préserver
vous savez quand je dis que je suis
inquiète je suis quand même motivé nous
portons une belle ambition et nous
sommes dans l'action boîte
paille-en-queue pape en ou encore butor
même si ce label fut une reconnaissance
l' équilibre durable du lieu dépendra de
chacun d'entre nous
[Musique]